>> Tucker: SO NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO IS WEAK
AND HAS BEEN WEAKENED BY ALL THE
HARASSMENT STORIES OF THE
IDEOLOGUES IN THE STATE ARE
BENDING HIM TO THEIR WILL.
CUOMO JUST ANNOUNCED THE STATE
WILL DISTRIBUTE UP TO $15,600 TO
"UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WILL
LOST WORK DURING THE PANDEMIC."
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT KIND OF I.D.
THESE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO RESPECT FOR
OUR COUNTRY, WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY -- WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO PROVIDE TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE
UNDOCUMENTED OR ENTITLED TO
PAYMENT?
WHAT IS CLEAR IS ALL THIS IS
GOING TO COST NEW YORK MORE THAN
$2 BILLION.
THE QUESTION IS WHO'S GOING TO
LIVE THERE ACTUALLY AFTER ALL OF
THIS.
[INDISCERNIBLE] THINKS ABOUT
THAT, STATE ASSEMBLYMAN IN
NEW YORK AND ASSENTED IT --
CANDIDATE FOR CONGRESS.
I'M SINCERELY WORRIED, I MEAN IS
FOR REAL, WHO IS GOING TO STAY
IN NEW YORK WHEN THEY START
DOING THINGS LIKE THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY, TUCKER.
THIS IS A DISASTER FOR NEW YORK
TAXPAYERS.
WE HAVE GOVERNOR CUOMO AND THE
ALBANY DEMOCRATS RAMMING THROUGH
A BUDGET WHICH IS GOING TO
PROVIDE UP TO 15,000
[INDISCERNIBLE] OF TAXPAYER CASH
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE GOING TO RAISE TAXES,
$4 BILLION TO HELP PAY FOR IT
AND THE KICKER ON TOP OF IT,
THIS BUDGET ALSO GIVES THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTED BUDGET
STAFFER, JUST A STAFFER,
UNILATERAL POWER TO REDUCE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT STATE FUNDING
BY UP TO 50%.
IF THEY DO NOT COMPLY WITH THE
GOVERNOR POSITIVIST NEW POLICING
MANDATES.
PEOPLE ARE BEING FORCED TO LEAVE
NEW YORK AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
NUMBER ONE.
>> Tucker: WHAT -- I MEAN
HOW -- REALLY QUICK, WHAT'S THE
THINKING HERE THAT, YOU KNOW,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, ILLEGAL
ALIENS HAVE SUFFERED MORE THAN
CITIZENS?
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD U.S.
TAXPAYERS OWE SOMEONE BREAKING
OUR LAWS $15,000?
>> IT IS AN AFFRONT TO NEW YORK
TAXPAYERS AND IT REALLY JUST
SHOWS THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO, WHO
IS INVOLVED IN SCANDAL, IS NOT
CAPABLE OF LEADING THE STATE.
HE'S UNDER IMMENSE POLITICAL
PRESSURE AND HE'S USING MONEY
OUT OF TAXPAYERS WALLETS TO TRY
TO CLING TO POWER, TO APPEASE
THE FURTHEST LEFT FRINGES OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY TRY
TO HOLD ONTO HIS SEAT.
>> Sean: THEY DID THE EXACT
SAME THING TO GOVERNOR BLACKFACE
CLIENT ROBES.
HE DIDN'T RESIGN AND THE
LUNATICS ASCENDED ON HIM AND
MADE THEM HIS MARIONETTE.
ARE YOU GOING TO STAY IN
NEW YORK?
>> I'M STAYING IN NEW YORK, I'M
FIGHTING FOR MY HOME STATE.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE THE
EMPIRE STATE.
CUOMO AND THE RADICAL LEFT HAVE
TURNED US INTO THE EXODUS STATE,
BUT I'M GOING TO STAY AND FIGHT
AND I'M GOING TO BE INTRODUCING
IN THE COMING DAYS A BILL TO
REPEAL THIS PRETAXPAYER CASH FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FUN.
IT'S COMPLETELY ON ACCEPTABLE,
ESPECIALLY IN THIS PANDEMIC WON
SO MANY OF OUR TAXPAYERS ARE
SUFFERING OR OUT OF WORK OR
HAVING TROUBLE MEETING ENDS
MEET, PAYING THE MORTGAGE,
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE.
I MEAN, THIS JUST SHO